we do another episode of honest trailer
commentaries the show where if you don't
know how it works by now watch an older
episode Jeff starred in Radford and
Meryl hello today we're speaking about
Batman Returns and after about 30
minutes of half-baked riffs we'll watch
some deleted scenes there yeah that is
the show this is I believe the only
Batman movie remaining for which there
exists no honest trailer so for right
now there's a lot of animated ones but
the and well and not the 66 well yeah
the only live action Batman movie not
including 1966 is back still it was a
little bit more of that sweet bat milk
Matt Reeves the Batman yes well do
Batman 66 I don't want to bear the lead
this is Joe's favorite movie mm-hmm is
my favorite Batman movie okay I love
this movie this is very difficult to sit
in the room with everyone you really
push it back hard on some thanks
everybody was long doesn't get beat in
the room for this one but I almost
jumped over a table at him a few times
on this one I mean Gotham City municipal
politics are to you like Kardashians are
to me I will I will go to war you'll go
to war over the Kardashians Cardassian
the Star Trek Wow
boy okay - you know I love this movie I
think they have the same name more or
less like yeah it's a Star Trek villain
where we have very long argument over
this joke going into the Starks are gone
it's Taylor yes because under the
parental race known as the Kardashian
yes you can't blame everything on
parental and I haven't slept in four
months long before your child was even
an apple in your eye yeah okay all right
fine
are we talking about even your eyes
how's Daniels with me on this I yes
Batman Returns is easily my favorite
Batman
I love this Batman I think it's I mean
it's obviously for me watching it as a
girl and seeing Catwoman and watching
her kick ass was really huge and then
when I go back and watch it it
surprisingly still holds up at least for
me even when we pick it apart which
sometimes makes me like movies less it
didn't yeah it didn't bother me at all
because sometimes while watch out like
can you guys know I pretty famously I
really love bad movies and so sometimes
I feel like oh I'm really enjoying this
even though this isn't great and then
when I start really analyzing why it's
not great it's like oh this is really
fun anymore this isn't fun anymore this
is this one's different
no yeah I know this was fun and
ridiculous I think you gotta love things
flaws and all you know and Batman
Returns is one of those it's not a
flawless film no my big issue is like
who's this movie about yeah yeah I agree
shortly it's like the whole doesn't
equal the sum of its parts
Shrek it has a lot of really amazing
elements but like would you step back
and look at the whole thing you're like
okay yeah
leymah happens it seems like the it's
like you have a lot of great characters
and they're all just kind of
ping-ponging off each other like Batman
like cat woman's got beef with Shrek
until like she falls and then she then
she falls in love with slash hates the
Batman and then like teamed up with the
penguin to ruin Batman's rep but then
it's just like it just seems like all
these characters just bouncing plans off
of each other and like they keep
changing what they want mmm or not what
they want but how they're gonna go about
getting it and then it kind of ends
Batman just adopts I yeah he should end
with people adopting cats right adopt
the cat the famous screenwriting manual
yeah they never show our reference again
in any other bad movie what that cat yo
really what happened to the cat well
it's very very took it he took it home
from set know economically like a
Gilbert Kilmer was like no cat on set
I'm allergic yeah mmm yeah where is the
cat man
our hashtag where's it's a big house
yeah you know I don't want a bat cat in
the shin the Schumacher films cuz that
cat probably wears a weird costume it
has like eight nipples on its back but I
do think one of the big other nipples is
a cat have probably the regular amount
we have to rewatch the cats trailer
catnip full discussion I'll see you the
first person I've ever met that spells
titties with a D no I just think he's I
think it's a funny way Wow again you're
throwing me off what I liked about
watching this film and revisiting it was
how it is silly and it is ridiculous
just like joel schumacher's movies were
it's just better at it yeah it just does
a better job yeah it's not the Batman
isn't silly in this film it's just fun I
pulled it off better yeah whereas yeah
Batman and Robin did not pull it off
right yes so good for Tim Burton we're
glad he got to achieve his dreams let's
watch our boss trailer for Batman
Returns good on you Tim Burton for
achieving your dream it's nailed it
buddy we didn't put the blockbuster
summer thing on them oh sorry Comic Con
we're - summer Comic Con
before he Reeves but before heroes and
even before he and Robin Batman returned
in its as Batman Returns you guys
after Tim glances funding amount of salt
and by making Batman cool again they'll
let him get his freak on in the sequel
with all the burden in cities you know
and love plus a dash of Frank Miller
grid a touch of Adam West's silliness
and to scoob's of the Batman
xxx porn parody a slight digression
about the titles of porn movies I was
very disappointed in the name of the
Batman porn parody which is Batman a xxx
porn pair do them great meme or there's
no like misspelling ya know and in some
of them they don't even change names
they just say oh well since we're
calling it a parody we don't have to do
the madmen or the madmen the Mad
Magazine thing which is a yes why even
hire writers come on
why put together a writers room for
these things Joe have 40 Batman porn
parity titles on my desk by tomorrow our
job because part of this is answering
questions one question that was asked
was why Batman
why man any number of them why we
believed when penguin says just the yeah
and they're looking for because these
are fright to a cat I understand that
but context maybe advert do monetization
yeah they they owe and it affects
everything the YouTube / mind does not
read context clues anyway so that's a
weird oppression and there's a theory
yeah that if the video is demonetized
that it might be harder for people to
find it doesn't get shared out as well
now I have no confirmation for that but
if you look at the views on Game of
Thrones mmm this is something like wild
wild west and the fact that they did
about the same well why about West is
more popular than Game of Thrones yeah
exactly yeah
was largely deemed unsuitable anyway
that's why if you ever want to know
blankets temperature little justice
again why we bleep or blur anything yeah
it's because we've lost our edge and and
also because you know that we do like
people to see our videos and
occasionally for us to be able to stay
in business it is to be there a part of
this people watching the videos yeah
and I say the p-word all the time to
myself in the mirror just screaming hey
creep children are watching this movie
metal clangs ooh their blue beans uh
poor people and by beats up I mean kills
yeah that means definitely very fine
this is a Batman movie think again
because he is not in it very much
Michelle Pfeiffer's star pause do we I
that graphic I don't know what the
source was is that in costume time no
that's Bruce Wayne actually I believe
it's from IMDB yeah it's reminding me
and it was made we just spec to me yes
so that covers both Michael of Michael
Keaton and it's the least Bruce Wayne /
Batman time of any Batman it's like a
Batman animated series episode inside of
like a weird fetish film yeah absolutely
hi it's a puzzle piece about me yeah
yeah he doesn't have a whole lot of like
scene chew and stuff like in begins
Christian Bale has like the great get
everyone out of my house on my birthday
speech stuff like that yeah just this
Batman yeah
not a whole lot of that yeah scenes are
great that he's in don't get me wrong
perhaps the best bat scenes out of the
entire franchise I love how big his
fireplaces may be will people see that
later
Koya national redwood forest and that
thing and it wouldn't fill it up that is
so hot you could be melting confirm fire
very drafty but it's all heated by that
central furnace I think Alfred just
chopping down redwoods make ionically
think he is yeah you're gonna pair that
bring a Wayne Manor between the 1st to
2nd movies he renovated the whole thing
to go from a stately English manor to
Tim Burton house on a hill yeah yeah
that's a lot of that's a lot of
construction breeze cross breeze plus
spotlights we have really that about
there yeah keep going wrong confident
woman only after a traumatic brain
injury
that is how it works and his horse gets
bitten by a radioactive cat or something
she'll become Catwoman I am an antihero
who loves licking Wow 30 cats and long
drawn-out gymnastics routine you could
just walk man she's so good in this you
know so Catwoman movie please oh yeah
does that scene though is I think the
epitome of what Spencer was talking
about for the entire movie which is that
Batman is in Gotham City
just finished a big action sequence
fighting a bunch of clouds penguin is
wandering around Catwoman is separately
in the department store executing a
revenge scheme extract and all three of
them just sort of run into each other
crates convert on their own separate
paths and they're just like yeah he's a
he's touring the streets observing the
chaos mayor stuff
run into each other on the street like
their own three separate sometimes yeah
yeah and how many times has the plot of
a Batman movie been like or TV or
whatever been like we can't just kill
him no we have to kill the idea of him
best
these are martyrs that it's gonna be a
martyr yeah the movie works because
inside that random interchange you have
you don't really think you'll win do you
yeah and like that's great everyone's on
their own separate paths and it doesn't
all really connect or sometimes even
make sense but everyone's so great that
no one cares yeah yeah she's and since
this is the Catwoman run she's so good
in this movie she's very good that is
constantly mugging oh she knows exactly
what she knows what she's doing for this
and so every I actually had out like a
run of all of the time she's like
mugging for the camera because she again
she knows who she is in this movie and
what this movie is and even as you know
the Meeker Selina Kyle she's still
making like hardcore nerd phases I think
sometimes uma thurman watch this Batman
Returns like with a glass of wine and
it's just like see what so right now is
this true yeah there's not really not
much difference no I'm a better movie
it's indescribable the difference in
tone and modulating things that the tone
is the same there's just like a special
sauce somewhere in but like Tim Burton
didn't ejaculate neon under the set like
the fact it's like that's there that man
that Schumacher lived or any black white
wings I love Batman like Batman and
Robin I like all of these in their own
special way yeah yeah they want some
yeah I don't know I think I think Tim
Burton had the contrasting yeah
somehow head gun is because this movie
is also very disturbing in ways Forever
and Batman and Robin are very goth never
Gaston
but yeah I think you know you can't
argue Ledger as the best bat villain but
if we were to have a program that we did
on this channel where you did have to
argue about things like that I didn't
think you can argue her I think we have
probably yes
fornication it's not a villain really
that would be my counterpoint I have
lost them as the villain at the end with
the Taser she was hiding in that cat
suit I don't know where she bet yeah I
don't there's not a lot of pockets there
what was on the whip yeah well she a to
get sewed into that like every yeah like
every time she did it they had to like
soar into it same with all of our half
its today yeah yeah personally my
clothing every day yep
anyways let's see what else you said the
movies were the whole universe is at
stake return to the glory days heroes
fought over what really matters local
municipal politics watch Bruce Wayne
engage in a proxy war over electing a
new mayor who will grant a rival
billionaire some construction permits or
something but we're gonna break ground
when we gotta break ground
I'll need permits the variances tax
incentives would fight on this and I've
already spoken to the mayor mrs. sky
beam but where the plot stumbles the
villains personality shine as
Christopher Walken earns the title of
cinema second best rag and Danny DeVito
brings a manic unhinged fury to the
penguin some rough of you soldiers the
white Arsenal's can be evil arsenal of
disturbing little drug noses
[Music]
[Applause]
our real penguins this nasty did Morgan
Freeman was possible you gotta just
admire Danny DeVito like going for it
man he's going for broke on this yes
yeah and one of the reasons why I don't
know Batman Returns as well as I know
Batman is that I was given license to
watch the original Batman as much as I
wanted with it I was not given that
license with Batman Returns because and
I will quote my mom said the penguin was
too gross I guess the black stuff is his
idea yeah it was mouth it's like they
don't spray it every time it was its
mouthwash which knowing that makes me
feel so much better yeah it's just like
dark mouthwash yeah so like they were
Kevin Costner in Waterworld in between
takes
mouthwash I do like to imagine your
mother just watching Batman Returns and
like liking it but being like not for
Danielle disgusted by it and for that
reason I did not have as much license to
watch this one as I did the Tim Burton
one and that's the rate McDonald's fame
is the whole reason to Britain largely
it's in a third movie because the food
was so gross yes yeah parents are like
do McDonald's like why are you putting a
toy of this drooling black gum lettera
lecherous
miscreant into my child's heavy eye you
know the only thing I remember my
parents being like nope is one day my
mom came downstairs and Janet Jackson's
video for if had just started playing
and she was like no I think that was the
one but I mean it was just Janet Jackson
dancin and a lot of mid-drift yeah a lot
of motive and that was where my mom drew
the line was was Janet midriff but for
some reason they didn't they didn't
notice this one and I watched it a lot
this is the best penguin we didn't end
up using the tape because we were
worried that I think we had some rights
his usage issues with Batman the
Animated Series but like do you want
this cool child stealing evil psycho
mutant penguin or you want the dork from
the animated series it's like he gets
beaten by children and then he sucks
it's kind of like villain and in that
where it's like he's a buffoon he's like
he's holy toy D and he thinks he thinks
he's like this high class gangster but
actually isn't it like this one is the
one from Gotham cool but I don't I fell
out so I don't know well I think that
Tim Burton really took a lot of these
character names as like just suggestions
like yeah man is a man who's also got
bad tendencies Catwoman is a yeah is a
cat woman and penguin is a penguin or
whatever that means razor tooth Superman
burgess Meredith everyone everyone in
the Adam West series is doing the Lord's
work
egghead King Tut Cesar Romero's Joker
Louie the life yeah
okay yeah horrific kid they're all my
Catwoman yeah they are they are Oh
crushing it in that movie but um yeah I
don't know this penguin just he hasn't
he has an army of penguins with with
rockets attached to their back like
that's the pinnacle for a super villain
like dr. evil couldn't get his sharks
penguin got his penguin something I've
got his penguin tiny tiny little rocket
I guess his clowns made them pretty it
was a back-up plan though did he they
make see this is the way it all falls
apart for me when you think about it was
like that was not his original plan that
was his backup plan right then did they
make thousands of tiny rocket launchers
yes just in case this went poorly pounds
of the munitions expert probably the big
one the Batman killed just want to show
Batman his bomb and it seems like
there's that shot of when he's like
we're gonna turn his car into an h-bomb
on wheels the tall guy who's like not
you Shrek like he's very proud of the
plan so I think maybe maybe him yeah and
the monkey his plan all along like why
he's going through the Gotham records
looking for his parents is murder kill
steal the first murder and round the
children as a firstborn czar because
that's what happened to him so he wants
to make everyone sad because he's a
sewer boy he just spends a lot of time
reminding people he's seen his poop you
didn't get a chance to put it but he's
just a sewer boy he's constantly like
making number two why are you so good
but take treated me like number two
[Laughter]
okay playing good sorry really sorry
Billy
let it be some Batman in this Batman
movie somewhere and when Bruce Wayne
isn't snacking in front of a TV cool or
begging the world to learn his secret
identity it's so cool it is also so
stupid
yes there would be so the bat-signal is
there like a just a chain of mirrors
that leads it all the way got them to
his house apparently and you can follow
that you would think that's a pretty
easy like you would think of you are up
high just literally follow the house on
the hill yeah like I mean if it's
anything like Edward Scissorhands house
like there's a suburb down there
somewhere and they're just like it's a
foggy night it's easy to see that beam
of light is shining that said it's cool
everything about this movie it's awesome
but holds no rationale wait if you put
any of us my favorite Twitter gif yes oh
yeah yeah good one but uh it's so sorry
thank you down there clowns clowns on
stills allowance with machine guns or
slowly advancing karate clowns no clown
is safe from Batman's vengeance wait so
let me get this straight
the penguin gets penguins and the clown
army and the Joker gets Bob so suit up
with the film that changed the course of
the bad franchise by grossing out the
sponsors so much they gave the next two
movies to Joel Schumacher the man
everyone hates we're making Batman too
kinky too jokey thief floor it's a very
bad one Harbor Edge's way to Cappy
respective source material you know
Batman has always been serious business
you guys like serious business story The
Bachelor Cat Scratch Pfeiffer ISTEP Jeff
love actually coccyx adventure Wow
that's Jeff Jeff marks of the Penguins
to Tyrell a posse of insane class adopt
don't job and who needs a Catwoman and
you've got yourself a caddy van
sometimes it's a most of the time it's a
waste of time I think I've before
Christmas
can't wait for pennyworth you guys get
that I so glad walking son for doing a
walking impression to his face thinks
they can do a lot of impression and
we're all kind of right can go save
yourself it's Kevin [ __ ] and J Moore
yeah and J Moore yeah Bailey the good
ones John Bailey he does have excellent
yeah firstly for Walker yeah that
starring is pretty solid yeah yeah yes
some of my favorite reads in this one
well watching that reminds me of some
other fun stuff we have so let's roll
right in yeah so do we get in front of
this I think well there's one joke see
if you can spot it if you can guess who
wrote it if you can guess it's debuted
in front of a crowd
and they'd last they did that left let's
say let's see if you can throw it what
we're talking about storing your Keaton
heart
that's the hotline hashtag me out to
death becomes her hello big mr.
fischoeder dr. mantis toboggan
I see Eman hurry up and get those loaded
already sell me this penguin more like
max Brooke
alright P Mad Magazine the guy everyone
impression of doing an impression fire
cats
Kitty and pee-wee's big abortion was
wrong it's Paul Reubens if you weren't
familiar Paul Reubens throwing his baby
carriage on the bridge in the unreleased
film pee-wee's big abortion that was
pretty funny and then decided it wasn't
funny and but it was but we shouldn't
but there's a lot of back and forth on
this was there was the conversation in
the room was really funny on that one I
can't remember what joke got pitched
later that had no reaction but it seemed
worse to me so this is instantly a
terrible story Spencer get me out of
this I'm gonna flat spin sometimes again
as they say commie sometimes got killer
baby the jokes you really love just let
him go
much like pee-wee Herman did with his
child in Batman Returns anything else
deleted 50 shades of way yeah okay well
there you go yeah
I'm not checking my phone we wrote down
some viewer response this one Angelo
Polly Chi writes I swear they already
did an honest trailer for this we've
done it three times this year yeah no no
we did just all the other one and Tim
Burton maybe the Tim Burton is in the
Tim Burton every time and in fairness I
don't remember every one we've done I'm
like well we really haven't done that
movie yet we've got the world's never
yeah yeah no we have not done and on to
trailer for Batman Returns yeah until
now we have now he's accurate
Beltzer double-oh-seven to which i
assume is a Richard Belzer biggest fan
for anyone who's wondered who Shrek son
is it's Andrew bryniarski who played
Leatherface in the Texas Chainsaw
Massacre remakes so I believe he played
um what's his name big dumb Russian
character in the Street Fighter movie
Wow okay all right I wish he had done
the Walken impression in that to give
you a great see which one of these are
good Tim Burton said Batman has less
screen time as for Milton Jackson to
give him privacy and keep from
overexposure do you agree give him
privacy I think what he says if Batman
was like a monster in a slasher movie
like you don't want to keep overplaying
the here's the monster here's the
monster I will agree like for example
the Batman Forever does have the saber
of Batman sitting in a car in the
courtroom yes
right that is a bit much I agree you
need to give Batman a little more
mystique than this like hello my next on
the docket yeah yeah well ex-rights
that's a projection on Tim Burton's
parties were privacy fans right now this
is one of the last true old Hollywood
style backlot blockbusters and the
Christmas lighting scene there's like 27
people and the monarch theatres in the
background of every after street scene
yeah you know what about this movie
couldn't could not be replicated today I
used to eat my when I worked at Warner
Brothers I would the stairs where he
saves the mayor's baby which is also
where the pen was mightier than the
sword and 18 I need to eat my lunch on
those stairs every day that's cool
yeah there's there is a weird magic to
the the Warner's back lot especially
that yeah and there's this there's the
tree lighting ceremony and there's like
two other speeches that we didn't make
any bones out of it but like they're
very sparsely attended press conferences
you can tell that they're all cramped
onto a lot yeah movie magic a lot of
people okay so not not about Batman
Returns but the boys honest trailer
honest trailer keeps coming up right
before this video yes they are
sponsoring this one and whoo so we made
them the the pre-roll that's why and a
lot of people asking why is there not a
Tarantino themed trailer into that yes
say man we will I think we can say we
will I just don't want to do it right
now it's like movies this week right
after comic-con yeah yeah because once
upon a time in Hollywood is opening this
week a lot of people were like they're
gonna do every Quentin Tarantino movie
and we did discuss it but those trailers
take a very long longer than a normal
one we this was coming out the week
after comic-con which means it would
have been in production leading up to
comic-con we're already that is like mmm
that in the end of the year are like our
busiest times of the year we just done
every Marvel movie yeah like the entire
MCU so yes
i'ma thrown skate and seasons whatever I
threw my eater would yeah six through
eight we have whatever we did I don't do
it for the for the digital release of
yeah it's upon a time in Hollywood or
something yeah we didn't want to take on
another huge one right now it was too
much alright too much for the workload
sorry I hope people were disappointed
we'll do it we'll do it someday
yeah fee fee yeah there's your preview
fee yeah he makes himself say the N word
a lot which is weird samuel l.jackson
will be somewhere yeah yeah there's a
preview and and more v yeah
that's all I have to say I'm Batman
Returns any final thoughts so it's good
movie good movie don't make them like
this anymore yeah I just kind of wanna
start sharing backlot facts where they
filmed the sequel to Purple Rain
graffiti bridge there's a sequel to
Purple Rain called graffiti bridge oh my
god 30 rock bit like it's racy market
was and directed by Prince and it's all
on the back lot they're still trying to
make it look like that Music Row or
whatever area in Minneapolis awesome
it's amazing I will tell you that where
Robin fights that black light gang and
yes forever is the same alley where Mary
Jane and spider-man have the upside-down
kiss and when the t-rex chases the Jeep
in Jurassic Park they run right by where
Kermit sings a Rainbow Connection in the
beginning the Muppet movie movies are
weird
lot max yeah so yeah those are the facts
for today and I hope you'll join us next
week where we will be discussing a film
heavenly it's just sent from above this
one mm-hmm so that's all you're getting
is a clue we will see you next week for
more honest trailers thanks for watching
[Music]